- Why hold back?
You can, you have one life,
just have fun and be yourself,
and don't worry about the rest.
I only sort of care about the music,
which is kind of detrimental,
because when I go down the red carpet
I feel like I'm going
to have a heart attack
and pass out and die.
When you do things and try things
that you're normally afraid of,
sometimes the outcome can be incredible.
- She's an American singer and actress.
Her debut album, "Yours Truly",
debuted at number one
on the US Billboard 200.
Her music videos have been viewed
more than seven billion times online.
She's Ariana Grande, and here's my take
on her top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well.
Enjoy.
(swoosh)
(inspiring music)
- You look back and you see
old Ariana to new Ariana,
and you think about
how much you've learned
and how much you've grown, it's insane.
- Yeah.
- Can you pinpoint
one or two things, like the
biggest thing you've learned
over the last maybe four years?
- When, ah, I guess when you just like...
Be yourself, you know?
- Yeah.
- And in your most genuine possible way.
And are completely unafraid,
that's when everything
starts to fall into place.
And that takes a while.
Especially with so much
public, like you know,
rumors and opinions,
- Of course.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- It's like,
you get scared and you
want to hold back a little.
But then I was like, you know what, like,
none of this would be
happening if I would just show,
like, just was like
gah, and was just myself
when I went out and I was my silly self,
and then you go, and it all goes away,
and then you're like that's me and
- It's a life changer.
- you don't like it,
there you go, yeah, when
you let go and you're like,
here you go, take it or leave it.
- Whether you like it or not.
- That's as simple
as it can be, it's like, why hold back?
You can, you have one life, just have fun
and be yourself and don't
worry about the rest,
it all falls into place.
For me, music has always
come first and foremost,
so that's like, I, I really
only care about the creative.
Like I only care about, like,
becoming better at my craft
and creating and writing
and expressing myself
and you know, training,
you know, practicing dance,
getting better, like trying
to become more comfortable.
You know, for me, that's
the most important thing,
so when I do things like
that, or photoshoots
or things like that, it
does take a lot more work.
But I do feel like I'm, I'm
getting a little better at it.
I've just been, like, I've
been working but also like,
working on things that I really want
to be working on right now,
which is really exciting.
Um, and very fulfilling.
I'm very
- Like, like what?
- Like new music, which is so exciting,
'cause I thought that since
I just put an album out,
that I wouldn't, you know,
be able to start new music.
But I just haven't really left the studio.
And I've just been like,
making lots of great music
and been inspired and just,
it's been feeling so good
and I love that, it feels good.
- Yeah, I, I mean, I guess you
don't have to put new music out, but
- I don't have to
- when you're inspired,
you just, you do it, right?
- but I want to, yeah.
It's like, I love
creating and making music.
I've loved music my whole life.
And right now I'm in a
position where I get to do it,
and pursue it, and um.
It's sort of my, like, life now.
So that's a dream come true.
Um, if I think about it for too long,
it gets a little intimidating.
(laughter)
But not really, I really enjoy it,
and I feel so blessed and so lucky.
I just try and make music
that makes me happy.
And that's what I'm most passionate about.
I don't really like or pay
attention to the, like,
celebrity part of it at all.
I really just, I only, I only
sort of care about the music,
which is kind of detrimental, because
when I go down the red carpet I feel like
I'm going to have a heart
attack and pass out and die.
So it's kind of like that,
and I need to get over it.
But I don't know, maybe that's something.
I'm awkward and weird.
Well, my favorite song is, um,
actually, "Best Mistake",
with Big Sean, he's
one of my best friends.
Um, but it was an amazing experience,
it was a great learning experience.
I learned so much because um I,
like, I tried new things, and um I
explored sounds that I
had never done before,
like break free, which is um,
and yeah I had never done
anything like that before.
But um, it was a great
learning experience.
I heard the song when I was
working with Max and Todd
and they were like, what
do you think of this?
And they played it for
me, and I was like well,
it's really different,
but I'm obsessed with it.
And so I wanted to take that
chance and really try it.
And um, sort of um,
open my mind to something new,
something that I'd never done before
that was really different for me.
And I was kind of terrified
to approach it at first,
but then it became one of my favorites.
So I'm really excited about it.
And I love doing new things and um,
being surprised by the outcome.
Like I really liked it.
The last thing I expected
to hear was "Bang Bang",
just because I sort of, like,
forgot about it I guess,
I was so focused on the rest of the album
that I didn't really
think about it too much
and it was "Bang Bang",
and Jessie J was singing,
and I was like, oh my god,
I was like this is amazing.
And then the second verse came in
and it was me, and I was like,
am I about to have a duet with Jessie J?
And then Nicki came in and
I almost had a heart attack.
And so, that was sort of how it happened,
and it was a complete surprise to me.
When you do things and when you try things
that you're normally afraid of,
sometimes the outcome can be incredible.
You know, if you're, if
things are upsetting you,
make sure that your intention is correct.
Like, why is this thing bothering me?
Am I giving into my ego or is
this actually a real problem?
- Not a lot of 21 year olds
have a great concept of their own ego,
and certainly not performers.
I always thought it was really interesting
that you talked about that.
What sort of situations
have you had to say,
"You know what, I'm going to park my ego,
"this is about my ego"?
- Oh my goodness, well, it's really hard,
because, especially being
like, on camera all the time,
and things like that.
Um, you know, it's just,
it's very stressful knowing that you are,
you've, like, you know,
you've gone from being
just a person who loves to sing
and who loves to dance and
perform and make music,
to a person who is literally like,
material for people to write blogs
and then like dissect you
and like start things,
and put out
- It's full on.
- Inaccurate, like, depiction of you,
and have many people
believe it, and then like,
you know that whole thing is very weird.
(murmurs of agreement)
But at the same time,
that comes with the territory,
it's what I signed up for,
and if I were to worry about that,
that would be me giving into my ego.
And I try to not, I
just try to not see it.
You know, I'm like, oh you know what,
I'm be here for a while,
they'll get to see the real me.
They'll get to see, they'll
get to know all of it,
sooner or later.
Regardless of what
business you're involved in
or what industry you work in,
taking care of yourself
is a full time job.
I think that, you know,
singing and performing
and making music, that's not my job,
that's sort of like my dharma,
that's kind of just like what I do.
My real job is like,
taking care of myself,
and like fixing myself and
growing as a person and like,
taking care of my family and my friends
and people that I love
and things like that.
Like that's the real work.
And I think that that's so hard.
- You've done so much already
and you're still young,
so has there been a point in your life
that you've been like, "I
don't think I can do this",
or like it's gotten too hard
that you almost wanted to quit?
- There are definitely times
where it's very very tasking,
and very like, you know,
emotionally tasking,
I'll just like get home
from like a really long day,
and like go in my bed and
like cry for like minute.
But um, but I really love what I do.
What I do makes me really
happy and I wouldn't quit ever,
and I wouldn't trade it for anything.
My family is the most important
thing in the world to me,
my family and my friends.
My friends I've had since middle school,
since elementary school, and
I feel like there's a
work aspect of my life,
where like some of it is kind of weird
and some of is kind of is kind of like,
wow, there's a lot of
people out there that,
like, you know what I mean?
But I still feel like the person
that I was growing up in Boca.
Because I've kept such a
really healthy environment
around me, and I'm
really grateful for that.
Like my best friends are
my best friends from,
like, Pine Crest Boca, and like
it has been a really wild ride.
And I don't know if it
weren't for those people,
if I would still be able
to maintain that normalcy,
and that healthy bubble.
And I'm super grateful for that.
- [Interviewer] Earlier
this summer you were
in a donut shop, you were in California,
you said some hurtful things
about Americans and about people's weight.
A lot of people watching
felt offended by your words.
- Mmhmm.
- [Interviewer] What do you want to say?
- First of all, I mean, my behavior
was very offensive, and I apologized.
There's no excuse, or there's
nothing to justify it.
But um, you know, I think
that as human beings,
we all say and do things that
we don't mean at all sometimes.
And we have to learn from it,
I mean, that's part of our process.
We have to learn from our
mistakes and that's how we grow.
- I think a year to the day
you were on The Tonight Show Jimmy Fallon,
who's my, my mancrush
- Yeah.
I love him.
- Right, he's the best.
- He's so great.
- And you got to do
Broadway versions of rap songs,
doing "99 Problems", "Thrift Shop",
"Insane In The Membrane".
- Yes.
- [Interviewer 2] Did you, is that,
is that sort of the
stuff that's on your iPod
or did you have to learn the script or?
- No, that was actually
something that I pitched to them,
because that's something
that I love to do anyway.
I love taking very, very filthy rap songs
and singing them properly, because to me
it's just, it's really funny.
- [Interviewer 2] It's hilarious.
- I make myself laugh and some people
don't even laugh that hard.
- [Group] Aww.
- Yeah, I feel like I make myself
laugh harder than I make my
friends laugh sometimes, but.
- [Interviewer 2] That's
the most important thing.
- Yeah.
- If you're laughing,
then that's the most important thing,
- I like to laugh at myself.
If you can't laugh at
yourself, then you can't live
a proper life.
- No, that's so true.
- Don't take yourself seriously.
Mister President, Missus
Obama, what's up, how are ya?
(audience laughs)
Good to see ya.
That's good, it's all good?
All right, good.
So,
(laughs)
So thank you for having me, um.
I seriously, I'm seriously so excited.
♫ Now
- ♫ Both come on
- ♫ 'Cause the boys they hit on my booty
♫ All night
- [Women] ♫ Because
I'm all about that bass
♫ 'About that bass, no treble
♫ I'm all about that bass,
'about that bass, no treble
♫ I'm all about that
bass, 'about that bass
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Easter79 asked me to.
Also, if you want to nominate someone
for the next top 10 video,
please check the description
for a link to video where
you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned,
that blew your mind, that you're going
to immediately apply to your
life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Kevin Fiedler, Kevin thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book "Your One Word",
taking that picture,
posting it on Twitter.
I really really appreciate it.
Hope you're enjoying the read,
and the coffee as well.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- Are you actually sort
of always recording,
or are you kind of
- Yeah, I'm sort of always recording,
I've started working on the second album.
And um
- 'Cause I read that
somewhere, I'm like,
- Yeah.
- You just put it out.
- I know, but I just love making music,
so I don't want to stop
and I have all these ideas,
now that the first one is
out and I've had, like.
You know, I've gotten to read the reviews
and see what my fans think
and what they really like,
and what they want more of and myself.
I've grown as a person
and as an artist and um.
And I want to push myself
vocally on the second album
a little more and um, and just like
yeah, experiment and
tell what I, you know,
stories that I've learned
in the past couple months.
I think women should be able to
express themselves however they like.
I mean, I think that's feminism,
taking pride in your body,
taking pride in your work,
and doing whatever you want.
I don't think to be a feminist
you have to cover yourself up
or do something a certain way,
I think you get to be strong in yourself
and do what you feel
good doing and that's,
but that's also just in general.
People should be able to do what they want
and not be stereotyped.
I'm very excited because I got
to work on the album for three years,
so I feel like I finally did something
that I am really proud of.
And coming from the most,
like the biggest perfectionist per,
like you've ever met in your entire life,
that means a lot for me because
that I actually like it.
Um, but yeah, I um,
it's really cool, like,
it's like R&B pop with the throwback vibe
and the sort of do woppy undertone
and that was, yeah, that's what I wanted
and that's what I think we
captured and I'm very happy.
- It's like a labor of
love, it must be nice
to have like a perfect pie,
like yes, I'm so proud of this.
- You know, I've, I'm so, I don't like to,
I never speak highly about
myself or about my work,
ever.
- You should.
- But this is something that I am
actually very, very excited about.
(swoosh)